this morning we are sharing a story
about a remarkable journey to one of
earth's most extreme places that began
with a google search a british woman
named preet chandi recently skied solo
to the south pole she made history not
by being the fastest but by being a
trailblazer in another way roxanna
saberi shows us how the woman who calls
herself polar preet is inspiring people
around the world
for preet chandy breaking the glass
ceilings started with the ice under her
feet i remember looking on google and
typing in polar explorer and i didn't
see anybody that looked anything like me
at all at 32 she set out to be the first
woman of color to ski solo to the south
pole
day two just about to head out for the
day
dragging 200 pounds of supplies
drawn by her dream of making history
why is race relevant to you
i want to encourage people to you know
be proud of their skin color and proud
of where they're from and it took me a
really long time to be proud of that you
know
growing up in an indian sikh community
in england chandi says she raised
eyebrows when she joined the army
reserves at age 19 but she went on to
become a captain physical therapist and
ultra marathon runner
then two and a half years ago she began
pulling tire after tire
and she trekked across greenland
and iceland
all training for antarctica her goal to
traverse 700 miles in 45 days hi
everyone checking in from day 7 feeling
a little bit tired today i'm just having
my granola
with raspberries for breakfast
and i'm only on day 12. yay
trudged on as temperatures plunged to
around 60 degrees below zero
and winds whipped up to 60 miles per
hour
i have fallen over a few times
and obviously i have this cough um which
i've had since literally the beginning
i'm just getting a little bit worse
the wind was relentless it was so cold
and oh it was just like oh my god i go
down and down and think this is just so
hard
she'd never been so alone armed only
with a satellite phone audio books by
will smith and mindy kaling and her
thoughts on day 33
i'm absolutely exhausted i haven't slept
um for like 48 hours
i think to myself well i've done that
day now you know yes it was tough but
i've done it
i just made it to you she arrived at the
south pole five days early
so happy to be done um and be here i
don't want to just like you know break
the gas ceiling i want to just you know
smash it into a million pieces and i
really felt that do you think you did
that i hope so
because i look at you and i think look
she's brown i'm brown for these young
people she has
it can help inspires millions and
millions of other south asian people
around the world and she's made her mom
proud as i was a child i wasn't allowed
to do things there were certain things i
was allowed to do and i thought
obviously when i had my girl i thought
she'll do whatever she wants to do
but polar preet as she calls herself
isn't stopping there what's phase two uh
the full crossing of antarctica here i
am a little bit closer to doing that
she'd be the first woman to cross the
continent alone proving that for this
polar pioneer the sky's the limit for
cbs mornings roxanna suberi
london i just always wonder what is the
brain chemistry in someone like that who
just pushes them on and on through all
of the that adversity day after day
so cold it all started with a google
search presumably in a nice warm
apartment right right with a
refrigerator just right right we were
what 30 seconds in i'm like no no no
can't do it but congratulations to her
yeah well done